now the u.s president is warning that
russia could resort to using chemical
weapons in ukraine joe biden didn't
provide any evidence but said that
vladimir putin could escalate the
violence since he still faces resistance
from ukrainian forces
his back is against the wall and uh he's
now he's talking about
new false flags he's setting up
including
he's
asserting that we the america biological
as well as chemical weapons in europe
simply not true
i guarantee you they're also suggesting
that ukraine has biological and chemical
weapons in ukraine
that's a clear sign he's considering
using both of those he's already used
chemical weapons in the past and we
should be careful about what's about to
come he knows there'll be severe
consequences because of the united nato
front but the point is it's real
so what is the chemical weapon well it's
defined as any toxic material that can
cause death or harm to humans or animals
and that includes its components and the
weapons that release them
there are four kinds of chemical agents
and they're absorbed through the skin
and the lungs and they can suffocate
people and animals and attack parts of
the body including the skin eyes blood
and nervous systems russia has always
denied having chemical weapons which
have been banned under international law
for nearly a century but has long been
suspected of using them against critics
and russia's allies syria used them
against its own people in its civil war
let's meet now to febreze pottier who's
a chief strategy officer at rasmussen
global and a former director of policy
and planning at nato he joins us live
from madrid fabrice welcome to the
program uh so what's your sense here for
navalny is this the end of the road for
whom we weren't here anymore
well i hope not
but it's clearly
a doubling down from vladimir putin in
in muslin uh any any possible
leader of of a russian opposition uh so
i think it's a sad day for
russia's possible
democratic future
but it's unfortunately comes without
surprise
and as far as the chemical weapons are
concerned if putin deploys a chemical
biological weapons
what effect would that have on the
dynamics of this conflict
well i think it would bring your
conflict to a level that uh uh clearly
putin has no interest in bringing which
will be essentially
the west especially the united states
would be urged to intervene because i
think this will be clearly crossing a
line that's been it's been actually uh
mentioned by the polish president but
also recently by uh president biden that
weapons of mass destruction did not have
any place in this conflict so i think
he has to this is signaling obviously
he's trying to scare us from intervening
and he's obviously trying to terrorize
the ukrainian population but using it
will for sure take that conflict to a
brand new level with devastating
consequences for putin himself
so you have to wonder why russia would
do this at all because
are their backs really against the wall
as biden would have it or could they
just not just mobilize you know the
might of their air force to try and
neutralize the fighters in ukraine
i i think they are running quickly out
of options the fact that a couple of
days ago allegedly they would have used
a kind of hypersonic weapon is another
sign that they are using the kind of
weapons or threatening to use a kind of
weapon that has first no place in this
conflict struggle does not really have
an operational purpose so i think it's
it's putting trying to show that he's
not running out of options twice in fact
uh if you look at the the attrition rate
the russian soldiers casualties uh he's
indeed running quickly out of options
but we should not also underestimate how
hard it is for the ukrainians to resist
uh mario paul is on the verge of falling
this would be huge symbolic uh uh kind
of um
negative uh uh sign for for the
ukrainian resistance so and both sides
are in a way fighting against the clock
but the problem is putin is doing it in
a much more aggressive way
when president biden says that putin
knows that nato is is united then there
will be consequences
what would you say those consequences
could be what does he mean
well i think it would be wise for nato
leaders not to say what the consequences
would be that's the whole point of
sending this kind of ambiguous message
saying we will respond but we are going
to keep
basically the response to our own
judgment uh depending on what you are
about to do so i think this is the right
kind of messaging in my view it comes a
bit late
since uh vladimir putin started this a
whole operation with some nuclear saber
rackley which was left uninsured at nato
and more broadly in the west and i think
we have allowed him to get away with
this kind of nuclear weapons of mass
destruction signaling which we should
have cut short from the start by
signaling back that we will respond and
that those weapons have no place in this
conflict
fabrice appreciate that thanks very much
indeed appreciate your expertise